hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today the season 8 executions had just
released for all the characters of the
game and of course you know I had a hot
bond with gladiator and do it this is
the execution if you haven't seen it
already for the specific character very
brutal stabs right in the chest throws
that [ __ ] down curb stomps in right in
the forehead I love it
so I can't wait to use this I really
it's more of a quicker execution so I
might have to get rid of the these ones
because I have the longer ones for the
holding X button holding Y button so I
think I'm gonna get rid of fighting
dirty
only because I'm just gonna use the
scrum because this isn't really a long
execution it's it's more of a medium
it's not quick it's not fat it's not
very slow stuff like that so we're gonna
swap it with this one and we're gonna be
using probably this character and then
the other character so with that let's
get started with today's duel
so this opponent we have a rep 15
Valkyrie not really a great start
already first game on let's see how this
works I haven't bought any one today I
haven't caught me not really good
against Valkyrie but I'm doing ok
blocking these lights usually Valkyries
have to go for the top light and then at
the second chain that always she does it
again I might consider I think she's
catching on so I might not block huh
because you might go somewhere else but
if not I'm probably just gonna attempt
to parry it big feint
all right see I knew shoot she she went
side that's life all right
dashing top maybe damn I was a little
bit late I I called the move I just
wasn't expecting at that exact point
there's gonna be interesting fight
[Music]
I'm gonna try to show off the execution
as much as I can during this it's such a
fast move as well crazy fast she fell
for that elbow thought of stamina
interesting she's gonna regain it back
fast which sucks but caught her up
trippin with that shot the new execution
with them yellow eyes Braavos beastie I
like it
beastie it's not even a word bro I like
the I like the yellow eyes in this
effect from the I believe it's the I am
war emote that was showing it off that
was really sick I enjoyed that as a that
kind of made look gladiator look kind of
like a demon so I'm I'm loving this new
execution if I'm gonna keep it in the
main set of things I think I wasn't
really big on last season's but I liked
it this season so far it's a good start
let's get the out of stamina there see
if she moves okay I figured she wouldn't
she's a smart Valkyrie
damn called me oh good good it's
thinking about doing the zone but I was
too low on stamina I didn't want to risk
it sure we're not that triple heavy
interesting and we'll get the execution
again ground to Chelsea eyes again bow
give me yo head chick easy nice stuff
yeah let me know your guys thoughts
about your execution specifically like
for gladiator I personally like this
like I've said before last season's was
alright but this one's a good season for
executions but in terms of your
character whatever you play Berserker
warlord Viking you know any type of
Knight character whatever happens to be
I'll have to know your thoughts I still
have person weak to me I think the best
executions were gladiator totally non
biased Centurions was nice and I think
she goki's was really cool as well the
the head smush very similar to
gladiators just way more powerful
because that he's a thing so it would
make sense yeah she's catching on so I'm
gonna stop with the I'm gonna probably
chill out with the buckler hits real
quick because she's catching on to them
toast that ended and she went to the
backup but the toast AB catches a good
fight Valkyrie I was very impressed
about that I was thinking I was gonna
get three owed but three one fight that
ain't bad see what next game entails
next opponent is a rep 42 PK 145 overall
so I'm not I'm not expecting much from
this battle I'm expecting lots of heavy
faints in to bleed
lots of zone cancels because that's just
how PK plays and lots of bleed stacking
and I said both of those at the same
time actually they every single thing I
just stated she did amazing top to your
gameplay give me that chief what's even
the score of it dr. block game she got
me on that
oh that was close yeah if she didn't run
out of stamina on that zone attack I
think I'd probably had not touched her
but yeah I'll take this win well I have
it I couldn't get the the execution I
don't think I'm gonna be getting an
execution off this girl she's uh she's
very agile I don't like that I don't
like fighting peacekeepers I've never
been good at blocking their light stuff
you're a little emo real quick we'll see
how this goes
Oh big block getting better damn bro
Hicks him at the lights again
- before please that'd be great that'd
be actually great start to this big I'll
take the train all right I gotta get out
of this situation I'm very low help not
that not ideal right now no I walked
into it oh the big save that was close
so my intentions because I was a bit of
a long-range you know - - Sh I was too
far away to hit her just with a normal
move so I was going to bait that I was
like going to do the dashing top light
in hopes that she would react and I'd
parry that but she actually did what I
did she she did what I didn't want her
to do which was to do her dashing mood
and that was bad so that's not good so
thankfully uh I caught it and I'm and
I'm cool I killed her just in time so
now she's outstanding again cuz she
loves this zone doesn't she bought the
heavies whipped out the heavy and she
fell off the map bro she's not even off
the map she's just she's like half on
half off all right I'll take this 300
Win anyway but I don't think that what a
rift that shouldn't count or whatever
Gigi's and the last match of the day we
have the same guy who played the
Peacekeeper except now he's a instead of
a 42 PK he's now a 45 at Shinobi this
guy has such a diverse cast of annoying
ass characters for me to fight
good deflect to start that figured
that's because he was he was shaken I
don't know what his plan was there he
just kind of sat there so I was assuming
he was gonna go for it deflects this
man's is going to white spam me into
oblivion fainted his own
oh good deflecting that's gonna be it
for me he's gonna dash away from me
damn its whatever even if I parried that
move I would have died of bleed so I was
just hoping now I would catch him off I
think that's this guy's plan is he's
probably gonna start deflecting me and
then just he's gonna like spam me
deflect and then once I start bleeding
he's gonna run away like normal
shinobi's do I'm not blaming him just I
don't like this character very poorly
designed character oh we traded there
that was a shitty trade for me though I
was hoping that I could at least get
something out of this and I'm out of
stamina which is not good but this
character really doesn't have much to
open you off except they pick this guy
keeps falling for these guard breaks I
don't know if he's like that was a quick
one whoa what the [ __ ] hello game I'll
ran render the heavy shinobi cannot
faint the zone that'd be a good win for
me that's the one thing I always liked
about this character is that he can't
feint his own so it's like an easy hit
because even if you can't buy the first
one as long as you parry cuz if you get
hit by the first you're guaranteed by
the second and it's the same thing for
the other if you get by the third to
guarantee about the fourth hit so is
like you either have it you have
actually two chances to parry this move
it's actually disgusting
case in point
brother this guy's actually gonna like
spin into it into a like a Bolivian
right now well this time you got it
all right there chief just eat that
heavy what that's also what I like about
Shinobi's is that even though they're
fast they have such a little help for
and it's really good and I keep giving
this guy easy damage but I'm gonna just
milk him for that now thanks for that
one bud what the [ __ ] you mean bro that
should've hit this game trash hi this is
a close game that shouldn't be closed
there we go once again the same thing
with the Peacekeeper fight I basically
wanted to paint this guy into doing the
move since I was gonna dash forward and
with that follow up he thought it was
gonna do a top move he's gonna thought
it was gonna do like a top light so he
just whipped out the little sickle from
the right dodges it easy stuff like that
one more round hopefully I can win this
balls up and kick that is it really that
safe I don't remember being that safe I
was not I must have not been playing
shinobi was well enough I mean he hits
me at these defects all the time I gotta
show up with that
I'm okay so it's only if he follows up
then oh I missed the deflect I'm sad as
I miss the parry that's bad that ruined
it a bit that's gonna be it nice stuff
he threw the garbage
I was not letting him have that [ __ ]
whatsoever Ben clapping some crazy high
reps and probably the three worst
characters that I'm not good at fighting
pk shinobi in Valkyrie the only one that
would be left was conch but thank God it
and bought a conch this game I probably
would have quit the video by now yeah
guys that's gonna be the end of the VTA
hopefully you guys did enjoy it managed
to win all of my games especially
against some really hard opponents so
I'm very impressed with myself as well
having not played in a couple days
coming back in and fighting ret to rep
40 plus even though it's the same guy
and stuff like that still managed to do
very well here's the execution again if
you didn't see it I mean if you didn't
see in the beginning of the video I shot
one more time in the actual screen of
what it would look like stabs in the
chest rips is you know does a little
twist of his arm
smack someone in the head loved this
execution brain-dead if you want to get
it for gladiator highly recommended
personally it's a really cool execution
it's very its normal speed but I still
like it either way guys liked it if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new cover
the informational side or for that being
balance changes hero updates patch notes
and gladiator gameplay as well that guys
have a great Esther day my two most
recent videos would be on screen you
guys want to check that out
hi guys see you later peace go
[Music]